vous vous souvenez certainement de cette
polémique née place du tertre à paris
entre les peintres les restaurateurs et
les cafetiers cela propose des
emplacements la mairie de paris avait
annoncé qu'elle allait mettre de l'ordre
dans tout cela
depuis quelques jours chacun a donc son
mètre carré le reportage de bernard sega
l'arrêté municipal de 117 n'étaient plus
appliquées du coup le droit du plus fort
les lieux de réglementation par ailleurs
place du tertre 60% des artistes sont
d'origine yougoslave 20 % russe polonais
ou japonais le reste étant des actifs de
la butte pour chasser les faux artistes
et notamment les marchands de
sérigraphie made in hong kong
la mairie de paris a créé une commission
tripartite composée d'élus de
représentants du préfet de police et des
cinq représentants d'associations
d'artistes elle commerçants en fait il
s'agit de réserver les 150 emplacements
disponibles aux productions d'origine
montmartroise jalili a qu'un seul
critère pour démêler les vrais artistes
des fossés de vérifier que ce sont bien
les artistes qui produisent et qui
créent des oeuvres ici qu'il s'agisse de
4 qu'il s'agisse d'ailleurs de
dessinateurs et portraitiste
nous avons mis au point une
réglementation si vous voulez et une
commission d'attribution de cartes
puisque nous créerons des véritables
carrés avec des emplacements a dit
visuellement attribués et nous
choisirons des artistes qui créent sur
place et qui vivent sur place et non pas
du tout des vendeurs de soupe et
j'emploie à dessein ce vocabulaire un
peu dur
vous pensez de la nouvelle
réglementation ça va nettoyer un petit
peu plus garder quelques artistes voilà
ça va changer beaucoup moins la patron
de gens qui arrivent et puis qui savent
pas vraiment qui sont en rêvant 4 et
puis qu il sera aidé ou alors
sérigraphie surtout 0
en tout cas désormais l'usagé du
chevalier est obligatoire les
reproductions sont interdites ainsi que
le racolage
mais il ne faudrait pas que cette
réglementation aboutissent à cause de la
peur du fisc à faire fuir les picasso en
herbe